j'ai fait une séance de spiritisme en
bretagne ouais et on avait tous la main
afin au dessus du guéridon mathieu
gagnon et s'est mis à bouger il s'est
mis à nous répondent non et qui se
mettaient à poser de plus en plus et
s'est mis à se déplacer il a descendu
trois marches sans qu'on le place la
vraie question que tout le monde se pose
c'est vous aviez commun d'accord
voilà je vous jure je vous jure que
c'est vrai guérineau
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est mon frère
non mais c'est sûr et certain frères ont
été plus longs et
une fois qu'ils avaient descendu les
escaliers
tout ce qu'on voit là les rayons on
avait décelé donc lady rideau était
tranquille et ngoko
des commerçants
mais je vous jure que c'est vrai tente
mais aimez vous aimez avec tish su
rentrer en communication avec qui elle
faisait moins rire acquis parce qu'on
était en été en bretagne au large de
l'île de sein vous auriez me fait
rentrer en contact avec votre banquier
je vois pas le rapport mais joakim noah
redonne de losail puis alors oui et donc
est donc au large de cette ligue mon nom
que s'est noyé sur un bateau de pêche
non et c'est lui qui était dont le
guéridon as well as long as parlé
l'enlever
je vous jure que c'est vrai succès qui
avait avoué oui c'est fou c'est un mot
très peur à wade était dans le gard et
dont le gabarit en tout cas ils rivalta
qui a été dans le dérèglement pendant
toutes ces années mes pauvres non et
donc il me répondait qui es tu me l'as
ep son nom et tout c est à dire on doit
alors c'était quoi lors il s'étend il
répondit je t'ai noyer j'étais en train
de vivre on le sait qui s'est noyé mais
ce qu'il est mort à mr ben oui forcément
mais il est royal est ressuscité bien
dire les noms et mots qu il a répondu
oui oui vous me croyez pas du tout non
pas du tabac pendant ce débat nous
croyons pas du tout mais je jure que
c'est vrai que vous me connaissez moi je
crois je compte mes prières désire
annoncer un jour enfin de spiritisme en
son nom mais franchement des déjà on
voit déjà des jeunes est déjà bien
senties rituel vais boire à l'origine à
la méthode a déjà beaucoup fiona vous
avez du vin pas grave un phénomène pas
non mais alors moi je suis je suis comme
vous je crois pas trop trop moi j'aime
bien avoir des voyantes et des
guérisseurs de teaser j'ai discuté avec
d'autres anecdotes pas normal oui moi ce
que je ressens très très bien
en fait moi j'ai été initié il ya bien
longtemps à vivre dans d'autres époques
ah oui mais un partenaire tourner quo
[Rires]
depuis trois quatre ans on m'a appris
que j'avais été à la bataille de
waterloo ah ouais c'est très sérieux en
1804 donc je suis allé plusieurs fois là
bas etc et je regrette énormément parce
que on a perdu la bataille de la guerre
loin posez vous les bonnes questions et
voir exactement et je pense que j'ai
fait dans la cavalerie d'après ce qu'on
m'a dit voilà c'est j'ai raté jour là
j'ai été nul et ça je m'en veux
énormément écouté bah oui oui mais ouais
ouais j'ai appris à voyager dans
d'autres époques c'est très enrichissant
les boeufs c'est l'hypnose résilience du
rebirth du boeuf naissance renault a
cédé rebirth ouais ouais d'autre part
vous allez renaître ou dans une autre
émission autrement c'est l'hypnose
renaître en boule dans motus et
non je disais autrement c'est l'hypnose
régressif ton par le bernard werber dans
son nouveau bouquin fébrile a reçu sur
un
chien et c'est bon et ferme et eddy
mitchell et ça vient d'une étude il
paraît que les gens qui ont des lobes
d'oreilles assez l'on soit très
réceptifs à l'au delà et osons de presse
par mois 1 1 a battu pénètre un tout
elle n'avait pas elle est vraiment avec
l'au delà est là des lobes d'oreilles
frère il arrive aux genoux super
pénétrer non mais ça aurait accès une
vraie étude réelle abattant ben tu la
branche de minutes elle a elle parlé
cloclo et il m'arrive un truc qui a 8
ans ouais je joue vraiment je vous jure
c'est vrai vous avez reconnu pourquoi il
ya huit ans un soir je me couche et je
fais un rêve et je vois tf1 m'appeler
pour une émission de télé réalité non il
jure que c'est vrai deux semaines après
écoute moi bien je reçois un coup de
téléphone de de tf1
fabrice bay chai prix acteurs du
divertissement merci beaucoup il me
reçoit dans son bureau et il me dit à
l'époque laissaient pas émission il me
dit on pense à toi pour animer carré vip
non carré vip trop rouge à lèvres je
l'avais entièrement rêver deux semaines
avant alors que j'étais petit lob dont
armand je suis pas réceptifs tu vois
mais ça s'appelle juste un rêve
prémonitoire guen pas du tout ça rien
mais c'est quoi à réprimander toi c'est
quoi tu
rêve pas de nom pas de couac le même
mondial et fait le même rêve
et tf1 l'avait appelé pour karim
alors s'arrêter un naufrage came from
catastrophe arrive du monde à leur façon
j'ai fait 2 2 entretien et à vous
pouviez le faire vous vouliez faire bah
moi évidemment on est toujours le pire
pour les oui mon passé et ils m'ont dit
d'entraînement aurions préféré elle a
fire ah oui et ça s'est cassé la gueule
peut-être à cause de ça au jeu mais mais
en tout cas je l'avais rêvé entièrement
la nuit avant c'est fou quand même c'est
fou by web c'est fou mais que c'est quoi
voilà vous avez eu des bonnes oui c'est
vrai mais moi j'aimerais arriver - non
mais vous recevez des choses non je
ressors ne donnait rien aux gens de rien
rien ne va rien faire plaisir vous ouais
vous pénètre si on voulait me dire un
truc
vous dire et c'est pas près de le
pénétrer une
petit à petit élections
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
cinquante ans un petit événement où il y
tient c'est quand même étrange il n'en
est rien et étrange quand vous avez fait
the cover vous n'avez pas senti la merde
si tu peux leur donner le score
quasiment de surprises mais quasiment
jour du gras de son bilan prime sur ces
8 c'est à dire quinze ans
vous vous êtes visionnaire pour les
émissions de télé les productions est ce
que vous pensez pas vu des gens
travaillaient pour vous dans du
paranormal pour que vous réussissiez moi
je retenais lots des gens vous parlez
beaucoup trop fort
c'est là je ne pense pas que vous pensez
pas je ne pense pas que vous avez du jeu
un phénomène paranormal vous jo et
nettoie avec d'anciens hommes politiques
peut-être non non pas d'anciens en
général ils vivent longtemps donc on a
le temps de leur période de leur vie
tant mieux pour moi non mais moi rêves
prémonitoires oui mais c'est pas très
drôle donc i'm here est un peu plat
après vous mets et comme belmondo est
mort fin j'en ai rêvé quelques jours
avant a mal pris et
il était très malade et tout le monde
sauvage on sait pas lui matin la partie
de moi j'ai pas rétro minutes origin ge
est un témoignage gould et fit je vois
delphine toutes les nuits avez-vous pas
du genre un témoignage bouleversant en
fait pendant des années quand je
m'endormais j'entendais une étrange
musique indienne
ah oui et qui en paie mes nuits comme ça
donc je flippais vraiment j'ai fait des
recherches j'ai cru que l'immeuble où
j'habitais été construit sur un
cimetière indien en fait au bout d'un an
je suis rendu compte qu'ils avaient
juste un restaurant indien en bas de
chez moi
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes très drôle oui moi j'avais
j'ai une amie fin j'avais une amie qui
avait emménagé dans un appartement
qu'elle sentait un peu étrange et son
chien et réagissent et assez bizarrement
il allait un peu partout dans
l'appartement il n'était pas bien et le
soir dans cet appartement le soir dans
cet appartement
elle entendait des bruits comme si dans
la salle de réception il se tenait un
bal et on entendait des échos des bruits
de verre etc mais bien jean charles
pendant des années il ya eu et en fait
comme elle est comme elle a vécu en paix
en disant pas écouté alesi enfin voilà
n'avait pas peur de ces entités et bas
pendant des années les teintes et
appartements et donc pendant des années
le soir à partir de minuit avec comme un
ballet la fin de l'histoire merci tu vas
le
chantier
les jeunes adorent mais je sentais que
ça partait mal parce que c'est ce que
vous voulez qu'on est vraiment une
histoire époux weekly 16h besoin
d'histoire est que
[Applaudissements]
je vous épargnerai celle sur mon père
pascal héry poubelle est vrai et images
j'ai vécu une séance d'exorcisme en
mayenne et honnêtement c'était
absolument terrifiant alors voilà donc
c'était quelque chose nous dit que
c'était de la merde les tueries tuerie
beaucoup à ce que tu dis voilà quand ils
s'enferment dans l'année c'est dans ce
sens que eelv et horner quand on
accorder ou barre toi
je voulais aller lui qu'on terminerait
par un truc rip